we are in wine country for wine country
you guys look amazing welcome welcome to
our home humble abode so first of all
ami given that you directed this film
was there a wine limit well when we were
actually shooting no one was really
imbibe and remember you know it's it's
long days and you know you're rolling at
6:30 in the morning so but on the
evening on the evening hours yeah after
cut there was a lot of dinners to be had
I totaled the entire time I didn't drink
for like and then at the very end I had
in fact it was here at this winery where
we had finished our third day of rolling
down a hill and I had my first class and
it was the most delicious glass I drink
I'm the way to the airport to come shoot
yeah who would you say in this cast is
you know the first one down and then the
last one standing first one down one
down well you're not shy about saying
it's time for me to go to bed and I
really I really have taken that cue from
you because I used to sort of say to the
group like yeah I'm tired but I'm gonna
keep going when I'm tired now I say I'm
tired and that's okay I'm not leaving I
love leaving first I also have changed
as I've gotten older I also like being
first at a party which I used to never
want to be I never and I thought it was
uncool right like eight o'clock is the
party get there at 9:30 you know and now
I feel like you get there early and you
get to see the person who's hosting
actually have a moment with them and
then you leave when it starts getting
busy really antisocial like 15 more
years you'll be fine absolutely right
it is it is right my introverted
tendencies have really come alive is
there anyone that's just like the last
one standing that you know she's the
last one to leave the party in this
group I'm kind of a night owl yeah I
always I always just naturally and I
also if I get if I drink too much wine I
end up having like a little coke or a
little espresso and then I'm like jacked
up again yeah
we did that in the show so much at SNL
of coffee and not booze but you know
there would just be so much like coffee
and you get super super tired and they
need coffee up and I'm so used to like
burning my adrenals out that's true yeah
Dratch Rachel Dratch is also slow and
steady wins the race kind of she often
closes down the body maybe quiet by the
end of the evening and you might see her
peepers kind of shutting a lot more but
she's she might even be asleep for like
the last hour with her eyes open if you
were to pick any other celebs to join
your wine lovers group who would you
guys pick Irish cherry Jones had been
with us more yeah I can't get enough of
that Frances Victorian yeah she's a lot
she said she's a lot of wonderful yeah
maybe Chrissie Hynde oh I can't we have
musicians in there
check you out right or or Liz Oh
Lizza with us sit with us listen I think
was a good call awesome well thank you
ladies so fun so happy to be here have a
good day thank you
[Music]
you